[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing the ones
of the wizarding world now if you're any
sort of harry potter fan
at all then you'll know that ones are
tools that witches
wizards use to channel their magic we're
introduced to olivander's one shop
right near the beginning of the
philosopher's stone when harry is
picking up his supplies for hogwarts
harry is ultimately given an 11 inch
wand made of holly
with a phoenix feather core and what's
interesting about ones
is that they choose the wizard rather
than the other way around
wizards and ones share an almost
symbiotic relationship
and that's why some ones simply won't
work for certain people
a wand is the object through which a
witch or wizard
channels his or her magic it's made from
wood and has a magical substance at its
core
ones made by olivander have caused a
phoenix feather
unicorn hair or dragon heart string and
are of
varying woods lengths and flexibilities
as shown above ones come in a variety of
shapes
colors sizes flexibilities and materials
the main parameters that differentiate
each one are as follows
length wood type and lastly core type
each element is just as important as the
last length generally pertains to the
size
and or character of the witch wizard
most ones are between
9 and 15 inches long wonder makers often
match the one length to the height
of the witch or wizard who will use it
but olivander considers this measure
inadequate
in his experience longer than average
ones tend to be drawn to those with a
physical peculiarity or a bigger
personality
whereas abnormally short ones select
people whose character
lacks in something similar to the length
the chosen
would for the wand also takes into
account the witch
wizard's individuality and the type of
wood that is eventually chosen
can be considered an extension of their
personality
you can tell a lot about a person from
their wand lastly we have the topic of
today's video
the wand core like the wood the wand
core will act as an extension
of the wizard themself allowing them to
properly tap
into their most powerful innate magical
abilities if you have the right wand
then you will always be able to channel
your magic
better than with a less suited
counterpart the windmaker of which we
are most familiar
ollivander has a tendency to utilize
three primary wand cores
phoenix unicorn and dragon however what
i want to discuss in this video
are some of the other lesser-known cores
first
let's see what ollivander has to say
about the three that he personally uses
early in my career as i watched my one
to make a father wrestling with
substandard one core materials
such as kelpie hair i conceived the
ambition to discover
the finest cause and to work only with
those when my time came to take over the
family business
this i have done after much
experimentation and research
i concluded that only three substances
produced ones of the quality
to which i am happy to give the
illustrious name of ollivander
unicorn hair dragon heart string and
phoenix feather
each of these costly and rare materials
has its own distinct properties
so as you can see above though
ollivander is fully aware of the
presence of other available one core
materials
he chooses to stick with dragon phoenix
and unicorn
because they are the most reliable and
allow him to consistently make
powerful ones this makes sense because
they are all powerful creatures
however there are other types of cores
and i think that ollivander is being a
little unfair here
as i'm sure some of the others have
benefits as well
in this video i'm going to be taking a
look at them all
let's start with the big three number
one dragon
from pottermore as a rule dragon
heartstrings produce
ones with the most power and which are
capable of the most flamboyant spells
dragon ones tend to learn more quickly
than other types
while they can change allegiance if one
from their original master
they always bond strongly with the
current owner the dragon wand tends to
be easiest
to turn to the dark arts though it will
not incline that way of its own accord
it is also the most prone of the three
cause to accidents
being somewhat temperamental number 2
phoenix
from bottomless phoenix feathers are
capable of the greatest range of magic
though they may take longer than either
unicorn or dragon calls to reveal this
they show the most initiative sometimes
acting of their own accord
a quality that many witches and wizards
dislike
phoenix feather ones are always the
pickiest when it comes to potential
owners
for the creature from which they are
taken is one of the most independent
and detached in the world number three
unicorn
from pottermore unicorn hair generally
produces
the most consistent magic and is least
subject to fluctuations
and blockages ones with unicorn cores
are generally the most difficult
to turn to the dark arts they're the
most faithful of all ones
and usually remain strongly attached to
their first owner
irrespective of whether he or she was an
accomplished witch or wizard
okay so now that we've got the big three
out of the way let's dive in to the
lesser known stuff
number four vela vela hair wands
come from well vela semi-human magical
beings
that resemble beautiful women with white
gold hair and moon
bright skin fleur de la cour notably has
a villa hair core in her wand
and olivander has described villa hair
as highly temperamental
which makes sense i suspect that
grakorovich
may have used vela hair in his wands
number five basilisk
it has been expressed that the horn of a
basilisk can be used as a wand core
and was notably used by hogwarts founder
salazar therein
for his own wand this should come as no
surprise
given his affinity for basilisks giant
serpentine beasts
often associated with dark wizards
number six
wampus cat jumper's cat hair is a cool
material used
by american wand maker johannes jonker
the wampus cat is a magical cat
native to the united states and is
actually the symbol for one of the
houses
at ilvermorny's school number seven
thunderbird
thunderbird tail feathers come from the
famously powerful magical beast
the thunderbird a large cousin of the
phoenix that's capable of causing
storms the thunderbird is also one of
the house symbols
at ilvermorny's school number eight
snallygaster
the stanley snallygaster heartstring
core comes from the magical beast
the snellygaster the core was used by
izoltser
to make ones for some of those that
began attending ilvermorny school
number 9. jackalope another of the one
core types utilized by izoltser of
ilvomoni
the jackalope antler comes from the
fabled jackalope
a mythical creature from north american
folklore described as a jackrabbit with
antelope horns
number 10 rugaru rugaru hair comes from
the dangerous dog-headed magical beast
that inhabits the us rugaru are said to
resemble werewolves
sporting the head of a dog and the body
of a human
rugaru hair cores are used by american
winemaker
vyoletta bovey some believe that rugaru
hair
has a connection with the dark arts
since rugaru are highly dangerous
magical beasts seraphina pickery former
president of makusa
has a brugaru hair in her wand number
11.
thestral thestral hair comes from the
fabled magical beast
the thestral if you weren't already
aware thestrals are a breed of winged
horse with a skeletal body
faced with reptilian features and wide
bat like wings
the argument could be made that the
thestral hair core is the most powerful
of all
one cores as the elder wand itself is
the only wand in existence
known to use it however it is also
possibly the most unstable
and most difficult to use of all of the
cores
number 12 troll control whiskers cause
come from the facial hair of trolls
massive albeit stupid creatures that
exist in the magical world
troll whisker cores are considered to be
a relatively inadequate wand material
however they are passable number 13.
dittony dittony stalk cores are the only
cause in canon
that come from plants at least it's the
only one that we know about
dittony is a powerful restorative
healing herb that may be eaten raw
to cure shallow wounds number 14
horned serpent horned serpent horns are
taken from
you guessed it horned serpents large
magical snakes with a multitude of
abilities
the core was used by izoltser and is
said to be exceptionally powerful
additionally the wonder core itself is
sensitive to parcel tongue
and is said to vibrate when parcel
tongue is being spoken
the core also warns the owner of danger
by emitting a low
musical tone number 15. white river
monster
white river monster spines come from
white river monsters a magical fish
native to the white river
in arkansas the wand core was pretty
much exclusively used by one maker
thiago quintana and the cores were
thought to produce
spells of great elegance and force
number 16
bone apparently all sorts of bones can
be used as one
cause there's no canon evidence anywhere
to suggest
that any particular type of bone is
better but apparently
they can be used once containing a bone
core
may also simultaneously contain a shell
number 17 shell similar to the peculiar
use of bone above
it has been expressed that shell can be
used as a wand core newt scamander
notably had a wand with elements of
shell in its core
number 18 coral coral exists in our own
world
a marine invertebrate however in harry
potter
it has magical properties and can be
used as a wand core
one to make a gregorovich notably uses
coral
one cores in some of his ones number 19.
kurupira kurupira hair cores come
from kurupira redhead forest dwelling
dwarves
native to brazil it is a notoriously
unstable wand core
but it has been expressed that if the
wand chooses you
then you must be a very talented wizard
number 20
kelpie last but not least well
sort of least we have the kelpie hair
core kelpie hair is of course from
kelpies
shape-shifting water demons native to
great britain ollivander himself
has publicly denounced the usage of
kelpie hair in his wands
early in my career as i watched my wand
maker father
wrestling with sub-standard one-core
materials such as kelpie hair
i conceived the ambition to discover the
finest
cause and that's it for this video did
you guys know that there were
20 different core types i bet you didn't
let me know in the comment section below
the new ones that you learned i'm going
to be making the same video but for
wonder woods
in the future also if you've taken the
pottermore wand quiz
let me know what your wand is until next
time
remember every human life is worth the
same
and worth saving
you